another day of protest ending almost
predictably
in running street battles between
protesters and police
this was the chimps archery district of
Kowloon where protesters had laid siege
to the local police station police
responded in force under a barrage of
teargas
most protesters fell back those not
quick enough were arrested some of them
shouting out their names and identity
numbers to let others know what had
happened to them normally busy with
shoppers and tourists some passers-by
got caught up in the chaos the day had
started peacefully large protest marches
against the government's controversial
extradition bill which has been
suspended but is claimed by
pro-democracy groups as evidence of
further erosion of Hong Kong's freedoms
within China life is getting tougher in
Hong Kong people are being ignored
now this protest across Kowloon was
technically illegal but it didn't stop
thousands from taking part at the end
most dispersed but others surrounded a
police station and this is where many of
the marchers have ended up a police
station where the officers are now
simply barricaded inside and the
demonstrators are in a wall that's
gradually making itself down towards
here despite warnings from police to
stay back the inevitable clash happened
the crowd being dispersed with rubber
bullets and tear gas
protesters have adopted a hit and run
strategy moving in smaller groups from
one skirmish to the next to create
maximum disruption now into its third
month the strain on all sides is clearly
shown increasing anger and violence from
a minority of protesters and from police
signs of stress at being on the
frontline week after week of what is a
political crisis the battle in chimps
our Choi ended in angry confrontations
between police independent monitors
journalists and local people all locked
in a seemingly endless summer of turmoil
Rob McBride al Jazeera Hong Kong